dude my dad cussed out like the [ __ ]
Bellman at the last cousin's wedding at
the hotel because they're like trying to
Usher people out and he's like God damn
it we spent thousands of dollars you
[ __ ] kick us out you [ __ ] human like
my dad goes crazy that's [ __ ] right
he's absolutely right yeah it's true
[Music]
welcome back careful boys we are very
careful boys and today we're talking
about one of the careful boys got
married
who is it who is it yes yes
take it away Anthony you guys Joe thank
you okay so uh yeah I mean um
hi Nina don't get mad at me for talking
about this she doesn't watch this
[ __ ] show wait it's Nina the spoiler
alert I know her mom watches this how
come you how can you tell us
you weren't invited
um why did you only look at me do you
look at anyone else because we were
there
Ryan were you there
I was there I'm the only one that didn't
go I was in there the can go Candles
there he was he was filming and then
deleting everything can you walk through
what letter becoming uh yeah so um so we
eloped we went to Maui and when I say
elope like I'm talking like we didn't
even tell our parents so it's really
just us like if it wasn't for the uh
hair and makeup Lady the photographer
the videographers like um and then the
uh kuya who ordains us of the island
type thing in Hawaii like we didn't have
relationships with any of them there
they're like was that people who work
for the industry so it's really just us
was it weird yeah I think so did it feel
rebellious to be like oh [ __ ] we're
gonna do this in secret I don't think
rebellious was like the uh intention
yeah you know what I mean it wasn't born
out of that so I feel like uh we didn't
feel that but it just felt
um it felt a different version of
surreal
did you guys go were you guys on the
plane going to Hawaii knowing you're
going to elope or what was it yeah yeah
so uh I guess to to take it back a
little bit
um so we uh I proposed her I think early
2021 early last year
uh and uh you know it wasn't ever very
clear like when exactly when exactly is
going to be the wedding how we're going
to do it all I know is that her her
family and Sylvia is not very large
whereas my extended family is like a lot
like I got this whole chinese vietnamese
like giant family yeah Lee yeah yeah
there's a lot of leaves out there
there's a million leaves
and uh Bruce
there's a lot of leaves out there even
though they're different leads
they're all they're all in the same man
same thing Robert E
Robert you're gone there's a lot of them
um and um
uh uh and then also just like in terms
of like when I really think about like
uh wedding I started thinking about like
oh I gotta invite like all the kendras I
got like the whole JK fan everybody's
got A plus one I got like friends for
like High School from College from like
this from that there's just a lot of
different social groups as well kids is
alone dude I know they just let anybody
in
that's gonna be honestly with maybe 500
to a thousand people like if you were to
invite everyone that's really in your
life it's probably gonna be like 500
definitely a few hundred that's like an
Indian wedding that's like when you're
at your wedding and you're not you don't
even see your chick because you're both
you're all working crowds the whole time
yeah yeah yeah shaking hands
um but then once I like got there I was
like man I straight up I'm not even
finding like you know our lunar year
wasn't exactly healthy for us um so like
I didn't exactly you know feel like like
it was a financially responsible move
and then let alone like just like with
all the the business things that are
going on like the entering the recession
like obviously there's you know as a
business owner you're seeing a lot of
different things especially in like
marketing budgets and all the stuff get
cut so just My overall sentiment during
the year was not like getting more
confident
um and then next thing you know too like
we had always dreamed about certain
things like we we dreamed about getting
married in Hawaii right but then um to
be transparent it's uh even for like our
own like family financial background
it's not like
um we would get a lot of support we
would probably have to like fund
basically all of it as well even for
like a lot of our extended family
um [ __ ] no-go yeah that was just the
pressure that I was feeling just to be
completely honest yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and then next thing you know you
start compromising things right we're
like all right let's not do a
Destination type thing so do you have an
estimate for what for what you thought
it would take to achieve your dream was
it like it was like I don't know 50 G's
or something or 100 G's or something I I
never allowed myself to get there
honestly I I we would like talk about
trying to be like let's let's keep it
under like 30 grand and in my mind being
like okay with it going to like 45 yeah
because like you know there's always
going to be things that pop up out of
nowhere right
um so just like allowing myself to try
and think there but then the second you
start like thinking about like how much
we were venue shopping both in LA and in
Hawaii you know what I mean at one
different uh time
um but once you start getting that you
start adding these numbers up you start
thinking about how much different things
start costing but it's all compromising
you know I mean it's like we cut out
like the destination because it doesn't
cost you much uh we gotta invite like
these types of people because like for
my parents like very Asian style it's
like I don't even really know these
people but we most likely have to invite
them hopefully they're going to bring us
[ __ ] red envelopes and we can cut you
know what I mean you start like doing
this whole thing and then uh halfway
through the process you're like adding a
bunch of Stress and Anxiety over like
the experience like I think it's
unavoidable when you're like trying to
start planning stuff things get a little
bit stressful and I just remember
thinking to myself I was like maybe I'm
overly practical sometimes or logical
and it's like it's like why are we doing
this like why are we spending like this
much money for this type of thing that
we're like kind of okay with because we
think we're supposed to do it a certain
way and you know and of course like I
have my own pride and ego and Glitz and
Glam that I want to bring to the table
if you know let alone like what she
wants to Envision for her perfect type
of experience
um and it was just a lot you know and
then I think one time we were just like
driving uh and you know I didn't want to
like complain about it so then we ended
up just like started like having fun
romantically talking about like the in
this [ __ ] mood like what if we just
said [ __ ] it what if we just like win
ourselves and what we just went back to
our original idea I mean he just went to
Mali and we were like you know kind of
riffing off of this like [ __ ] it
mentality for a second and I remember
this like slight pause and just being
like
that sounds kind of tight
it's like wait should we just do that
and then that ball just the second that
like idea started catching wind
like all the green signs like the green
lights were like yeah this makes sense
this makes sense and all these other
things that we're kind of trying to work
around and stuff which again
um you also like get what you pay for
right like whether it be like the
investment of time and planning to like
literally what you pay for like there's
also a lot of things that we didn't get
by like making this decision that you
know I would still love to someday
hopefully receive but something you
didn't get like for example
um uh with Nina uh she's the only uh
daughter of her father uh so even though
she has like half sisters from like a
different dude
um so the mom remarried uh so that means
that father has uh even though he is
like four daughters uh that's his real
one daughter so he's never really gotten
a chance to like walk somebody down an
aisle and just to think of like that for
for like my stepdad and being like okay
that's invaluable that's probably an
experience he wants to have yeah
potentially right we didn't exactly talk
about that but just thinking about like
that feeling you just took it from
or like um like a family photo like her
family and my family in one photo yeah
like how valuable is that yeah yeah for
sure for sure maybe we can like formally
concoction sort of like dinner or
something we got Adobe suite you can
make that happen yeah Ryan knows how to
get it for free
and he could put other people in
celebrities he's really gonna Photoshop
you can make your nephews like six feet
tall you know we give you a big dick oh
thank you you know family photos
dude yeah
it's a little cartoonish actually
thank you for the big I want to get that
photo back and go why is my dick look
small yeah yeah exactly my ball just too
weak they don't do that for you at Sears
uh maybe like um outside of even like a
day of the wedding the idea of like a
bachelor party or you know oh yeah just
the whole thing huh you know where like
you you get to hand pick you know some
of the the gentlemen to help you become
the man you are and then I was only a 30
minute playing right away dude you know
I mean like I'm always right there kind
of [ __ ] up dude
so just things like that like worse
sacrifice you know what I mean but then
what was gained other than the fact that
like one I'm not like in debt and broken
out of pocket for a bunch of [ __ ] it's a
big deal thank God yeah dude huge now
you're just in Denton broke because of
crypto
double down not the bottom
I mean there's so many people that start
a marriage in debt like in the deficit
you know in like a backwards place face
that's tough can you imagine how many
people out there actually succumb to the
social pressure and they end up doing it
because it's for the family and they
don't want to feel the shame and
embarrassment so then they blow like 70
grand that they don't have on the
wedding because you guys almost did that
yeah yeah and then while you suffered
through it and you're just like oh I had
to do it for my family but you're just
you know some people would do it because
they're just afraid of judgment and all
that I picture like Graham Stefan doing
like a for-profit wedding that's
something I probably made of work we
managed to figure out that if every
guest contributes cash you know we only
spend this amount on on you know
overhead and you know there are some
weddings that are like that straight up
I've heard of like certain like Asian
weddings and stuff where um you know uh
because they got that rich Encore Auntie
from Hong Kong or because they blah blah
blah you know what I mean it's like yeah
I made money on my wedding I'm like that
is amazing how did they make money on
their wedding some Filipino weddings are
like that where do you have sponsors so
like they'll be like 20 different family
members or church members and they get
to run ads at your wedding yeah
together and then all those people spend
the money to for you to have your
wedding and then on top of the gifts you
get you can walk away with profit I
think my parents had health sponsors I'm
I could go that route which I might
still have a family maybe wedding next
year you know because renew your vows
yeah exactly I definitely still want to
have like and share something with my
family and her family as well
um but in order for me to like go that
route uh would involve like one it's
like very Asian style two it's like uh
probably a bunch of people my parents
would invite that I don't really
remember or know anything in order for
like that you know yeah
you're already down this whole Lane of
compromise where you're like okay I
gotta uh hopefully get my money back but
I'm gonna spend 12 000 for like these
guests to you know what I'm saying so
that was something that I was like uh me
and you know we just weren't really
there how did that feel though at the
end of it all were you relieved like you
know what's crazy yeah absolutely I
think like the amount of stress is like
this is so weird I've been in it to so
many weddings and supported people I've
been on so many like you know Bridal
parties and been the best man and so
like I've really like seen and
experienced like all those things
um and so for my own the idea of like my
wedding day it's like it was just her by
herself in like one area we were at this
uh [ __ ] sick-ass suite at hotel
wildlands beautiful Resort right but she
was like in one side just getting ready
with the hair and makeup just mad chill
and for me because it's not going to
take me hella long and there's no crazy
like oh there's not an insane schedule I
don't have to like host all these guests
and families I literally was like all
right
uh I'm gonna take a nap yeah that's sick
you know what I mean so I took a nap and
I got up and I was like I'm gonna be
good for like later in the night
whatever and then it's like once we got
to like doing our thing and stuff like
that
um did you have the nervies like heading
up leading up to it yeah were you
nervous it wasn't nervous but it was
like excited Jitters just the you know
what I mean like it just felt yeah the
Thrills yeah it's thrilling exactly
um and then I remember when we went to
go actually do uh the and get ordained
and everything like that and we were
just private uh area of the island it
was really just us and kuya comes down
he blows his [ __ ] giant seashell in
all directions
and he's doing like this whole thing
yeah that's dope and uh and that was
huge for us because she's got a
connection to Hawaii with like you know
her family uh some of her some of her
family lives there my parents got
married in Hawaii when they like met
there you know in the 70s and stuff like
that after the war so
um I just like always envisioned and
wanted to like be in that space and feel
the energy so that was like amazing and
then when that was done we were done
there was no other commitments to
anybody else other than ourselves that's
the best it's so weird it was really
weird but it was it was over and then we
got to start our vacation interesting
yeah we're on the water slide I've been
to the Grand Wailea it wasn't a grand
while it was Hotel Wiley oh wait that's
good water slide yeah dude
the Grand Wailea has like [ __ ] three
water slides in it way less
and it was funny because uh when we were
driving back uh we were you know still
took us like 30 minutes the area of the
island we were on to like where we ended
uh going back to our hotel it was we're
driving back and we're like
should we tell someone oh yeah so then
we just decided to like you know it's
like who do we want to call we just like
called Charlie uh you know if you were
just like hey dude check it out and
she's in her wedding dress ugh that's a
crazy ass visual yeah yeah just like
crazy man that's so crazy like I didn't
get a call did you did you guys get a I
didn't not even the careful boys group
chat like not even saying
not even a sneak peek or nothing nothing
right not even a first look but I don't
even we didn't get to roast them first
yeah interesting I was trying to have
like a happy time I think that's why you
wouldn't even remember dude we love love
okay yeah we love love marriage you know
what's crazy uh like that was obviously
amazing and peaceful in its own way it
really was peaceful I think that when
there's like no stress about a million
other thoughts too and you're really so
focused I'm sure too yeah because like
for example like I know who I am in
terms of like the [ __ ] guy like if I
had a 400 people if I had an audience My
Vow was my vows would probably be
different oh true yeah yeah I would just
I would probably
subconsciously entertain because it's
like for everybody yeah yeah but then
because I knew I was in there just I
think but just knowing it was just her
suddenly my valves just felt so much
like simpler and like you know in a
different room it's truer
um and then it was when we got home that
we're like all right now we got to tell
our parents uh but we had told them all
year that we would legally get married
we would go to court and we would do it
you know I had all these other reasons
whether it be like loan credit this and
that so your vows nobody's ever heard
what they were huh no can you like give
us can you get some Greatest Hits yeah
yeah yeah can you give us a gif can you
give us a pun For You Greatest Hits yeah
it was like 16 bucks
or her ears only no no we we haven't we
haven't written somewhere but um but
what was crazy is telling our parents
and I think this is uh I think I was
nervous for that that was that was a
nervous thing to tell my parents telling
her parents she took it away from her
pops thank you well the first thing her
dad the first question her dad asked was
like
so you're gonna change your last name to
you or to her and she was like she's
like yeah he's like
okay and then after that I was like
what's your life what's your last name
no why did he ask that
curious that's a good question what's
what's your family name his name you
know what I mean so it's like oh when
you think about that when they don't
change it oh I told you because I was
like what's her name and see so and see
so Nina Lee sounds tight yeah he's
[ __ ] dope she keep that did she keep
her change her middle name oh yeah I
think so
um because it was her mother demanding
name before but that's a great that's a
great name yeah yeah her first name
company her first name is actually Anita
Dominique that whole her whole thing
that's a hot name honestly I call her
Dominique when she starts getting mad at
me I'm like hey yo Dominique yeah I do
that to Nikki all the time yeah Nicole
Alexandria oh really when she's mad at
you no one I'm mad at her oh or if she's
just not listening that's really what it
is because that then she'll listen up
and she's like why are you doing that
[ __ ] dad [ __ ] to me
and then she's like come on Stephen Paul
Green well yeah it gives her that chill
parents are mad at her or whatever yeah
Stephen Paul I'm like you weren't
hearing me and I think after telling
them they're so like cool and chill
about it though yeah it's cool and my
dad was literally like you're you guys
are old like do your thing you know what
I mean it's about time and uh but uh
after just reflecting it's like also
like me and Ian are both like the uh the
babies of the family right so our
parents have already have older uh
siblings that have done the full thing
yeah you know so it's not like they're
they're losing something in a sense
they've already been through it many
times uh so I feel like it was a lot
easier even for like you know parents
like I don't care I want to watch
Walking Dead get away yeah walking or if
anything it's like make some children or
some [ __ ] you know what I mean hurry up
and make a baby well it gets it does get
hacked if you bed but if you have like
three kids it's like holy [ __ ] I gotta
do this again I know my dad too my dad
gets pissed at certain weddings
especially family weddings you know
because because even for like there's a
lot of Saving Face that has to happen in
that like culture as well dude I get
pissed Church weddings [ __ ] suck a
Catholic Church oh no those are the
worst you gotta do Mass dude my dad
cussed out like the [ __ ] Bellman at
the last cousin's wedding at the hotel
because they're like trying to Usher
people out and he's like God damn it we
spent thousands of dollars here you
[ __ ] kick us out you [ __ ] you man
like my dad goes crazy that's [ __ ]
right he's absolutely right yeah that's
true and I'm always laughing in the
corner because like I'm that's funny
like are they trying to Usher people out
it's just like people like all the times
here and you only rented this section of
the blah blah blah for that so you know
you everybody but you know when you got
a bunch of old Asian people that are
kind of loitering you know what I mean
when they're kind of getting ushered out
by a younger kid and it's like you just
spent like 40 Grand on the hotel you
don't want that [ __ ] you're just like
dude you know how good could your vows
be if there's no witness because then
who's holding the fire the kuya at the
at the oh they heard it the spirits of
the island and my GoPro we have it all
on footage oh nice I was wearing a lot
of Mike too you know what I mean really
yeah it was because
you have to have someone observing right
yeah and we signed it there yeah the
makeup artist observing no no not the
makeup artist there but we have the
photographer the two videographers and
the kuya the cool yes all right dude
well congrats man congrats bro
we're happy for you Anita and I only
told you guys late because I wanted to
have all of you here at the same time to
tell but like for whatever reason since
the end of September until now we
haven't had a single time where all of
us were here oh yeah that's true since
September yeah it's either I'm gone I
told Ryan earlier because like by the
time we were at The Quest group party
which was a month later random people
who I hadn't seen you know what I mean
with like either notice my ring or like
you know what's like nonchalant it's
like hey did you get married it's like
yeah yeah got married and I'm like some
of my closest friends don't even know
because I haven't got a chance to tell
them that's your actual ring yeah that's
my actual wedding you told me when we
were having a little crypto session I
did I did because I wanted I wanted
people to know I wanted you know I
wanted to tell my close friends
especially if like random still friends
but just like randomly they would find
out I want to tell my close friends but
you want to tell people face to face you
know what I mean and then they were not
fighting out through Lord's cow or some
[ __ ] yeah I didn't even tell Nikki
though because I didn't know if you
wanted to like known at all so now I can
tell her well yeah now I gotta ask Nina
if she's cool with this video and then
uh she'll be fine she'll love it you
told me sometime
don't know man but are we just
co-workers too you told me sometime hey
to be fair I think everybody did find
out except for Nick
um that's about right because he doesn't
know about marriage yeah but that's
because that's the goal is never tell
Nick Nick deflects wait wait what's
going on guys what are you doing and by
the way that's a deeper joke than people
know yep I don't deflect it did you play
this though
[Music]
this [ __ ] makes me cry dude I know it's
a good song
[Music]
[Music]